what's up guys today we're going to be
making tatsu aka
chinese barbecue pork it's sweet it's
savory
and super popular cantonese dish tattoo
is iconic for its red color it's
actually like
bright red and for those of you guys
that aren't used to seeing
tattoo it might be kind of like was that
raw as a blood
it's not it's just food coloring so if
you've ever seen
at chinese barbecue shops that hang
meats and it's like super red
that's tatsu the color red and chinese
culture represents good luck and good
fortune so i'm
pretty sure there's some sort of
auspicious reasoning there so in
cantonese
tahsu literally translates to fork roast
tah meaning fork siu meaning roast so
the traditional way of cooking tatsu is
skewering
a piece of meat with a fork and roasting
over fires
hence fork roast now i usually oven
roast mine but today we're going to try
and replicate that open fire cooking
style by using my traeger to barbecue
some cha
soup so let's get started
all right first up ingredients we're
gonna need three pounds of pork shoulder
aka pork butt whatever you like to call
it we'll need two thirds cup of sugar
six tablespoons of soy sauce three
tablespoons of rice wine one tablespoon
of oyster sauce
one tablespoon of hoisin sauce one
tablespoon of sesame oil one tablespoon
of ginger powder
one tablespoon of garlic powder 1.5
teaspoon five spice
one teaspoon of white pepper and one
teaspoon of salt
[Music]
all right let's get started so first
we're going to trim the fat of the pork
shoulder so mine has a fat cap so i'm
going to trim that in any excess fat
that i don't think is going to render
out
in the cook process but be careful don't
trim too much because if you trim too
much you won't have enough fat to
keep your meat moist and juicy so the
idea here is to have a thin layer of fat
some meat fat meat fat meat fat and not
a whole chunk of fat and if you see a
huge chunk of fat
feel free to cut that out once you've
trimmed out the fat let's go ahead and
cut up
our pork into thin slices about two
inches thick
and once you're done with that place
these two inch strips of pork into a
dish
all right next up super easy is the
marinade
literally add all the ingredients
together into a bowl
and mix so go ahead and combine your
sugar soy sauce
rice wine oyster sauce hoisin sauce
sesame oil
and all the dry spices and once you have
it all mixed together
let's add the red food coloring now i
don't usually use red food coloring when
i make it at home but for you guys and
for this video i wanted to make it look
extra cool so we're gonna add that red
food coloring today now it doesn't
actually affect the taste it's really
just for the cool looks
and if you want to bring in some good
fortune be my guest so
add one quarter teaspoon of red food
coloring and mix that in as well now
once you have the marinade ready
pour the marinade over your pork and i
like to work in the marinade into the
meat and into all the crevices by
massaging the meat
and the marinade together and after that
let it sit and marinate for at least
four hours and if you can afford it
one whole night would be ideal
[Music]
all right so let's fire up the trigger
now and bring it up to temp today i'll
be cooking with applewood pellets
and we'll be roasting at a temperature
of 350 degrees
once the trigger is up to temp go ahead
and toss in our meat onto the grill
and let the trigger do its magical work
and we're going to be roasting this for
15 minutes so after 15 minutes of
grilling we're going to baste our meat
with the leftover marinade
we want to reinforce the flavors and we
want to add some moisture
so it doesn't dry out during the cook
then flip and baste the other side as
well
and now we're going to let it roast for
another 10 minutes now while the meat is
roasting for these 10 minutes let's go
ahead and make our finishing glaze
start with a tablespoon of hot water add
in 1 tablespoon of brown sugar 2
tablespoons of honey and 1 tablespoon of
the leftover marinade and mix
[Music]
after those 10 minutes of roasting we
are ready to apply our honey glaze
you want to coat the meat with as much
of this as you can on both sides this
place is going to add a nice sweet outer
layer to your chatsu and once you've
applied the glaze go ahead and crank up
the temperature on the trigger too high
and now on my settings it literally says
high there's no temperature that goes
like no number temperature that goes
with it my trigger on high
reaches about 435 degrees i think
ideally trying to reach 450 but maybe
weather conditions don't allow it to go
to 450. so if you're at home if you're
doing this in the oven
try 435 degrees and we're going to cook
it for another 10
minutes at high temp the high heat will
char the sugar content
in the glaze and leave us with a
beautiful deep dark red pigment
on the tattoo and that's what we want
and after 10 minutes of high heat turn
off the traeger
and let it sit for another 10 minutes in
residual heat
[Music]
then pop it off the grill let's slice up
our beautiful fork
roast now what we're looking for as
we're cutting it is to cut it into
bite-sized pieces
just like most chinese food when you eat
with chopstick stanley style everything
is bite-sized
personally i like to angle the meat a
little bit so i can cut diagonally so i
can get longer slender pieces
this way it actually benefits the
texture of the bite as well
tossing can be eaten with rice noodles
bread boughs
any sort of starch or you can just serve
it up like cold cuts just like this
but my favorite way of eating tattoo is
to serve it with the better rice
add a little bit of greens like bok choy
or choy sum and then fry an
egg and place it on top of the whole
thing drizzle a little bit of soy sauce
on top and then you have one of the most
nostalgic meals of my childhood
cheers
i don't know what it is about cooking on
the fire
in the trigger but it almost accentuates
the marinade way more than the oven does
the oven kind of leaves it a little bit
more bland
but maybe it's the smell cooks into that
sugary glaze
and it's beautiful gotta get another
bite
so good like always like and subscribe
and if you decide to give this recipe a
try
don't forget to tag me in your creations
i'd love to check it out till next time
[Music]